Bitcoin uh is up again this morning
actually it's been adding to uh its
gains up almost $600 earlier this week
uh it crossed 35,000 for the first time
since 2022 it's doubled for the year
optimism uh is surrounding the possible
eventual approval of Bitcoin spot
Bitcoin ETF that has something to do
with surge obviously join us now Anthony
Pompano founder of pomp Investments to
try to sort out anything related here
there was I guess some ETF news uh
although you would argue it was to be
expected so Black Rock yesterday or the
day before got a QP number that that we
knew they would have to do that right
yeah I mean look to understand really
where Bitcoin is right now you got to go
back to 2018 2019 Bitcoin had been up to
20,000 in the bull market it drew all
the way down to $3,000 what happened
there in Stanley duck Miller said it was
the thing that convinced him to go buy
Bitcoin is that none of the bitcoiners
really sold about 80% of the people who
owned it at 20,000 still owned it at 56%
long term right now so there's there's
no supply for it either it's highly
liquid 76% hasn't been sold in the last
year 56% hasn't been sold in the last
two years years and really what we saw
what drove bitcoin's price from that
$3,000 bottom to $69,000 I mean 23x in
about three years is that there was a
supply and a demand shock and we had
printing of money low interest rates and
we also got the having we look like
we're headed right back to that right
now we do have high interest rates and
they're trying not to print money but we
have a$ 33.5 trillion dollar debt
they're trying to fund two proxy Wars we
have a southern border issue we've got
all sorts of uh inflation they're still
trying to uh combat and so what's likely
to happen here is that they're going to
have to return to loose monetary policy
when they do that it is likely to
coincide with the Bitcoin but near term
uh just talking about the ETF you've got
nothing has happened in the last three
weeks to indicate it's any closer well I
definitely think that it's closer right
I mean because three weeks went by well
three weeks went by but also Black Rock
is now going and they're seeding the
fund they're seeding the fund in October
which is new correct and so they just
amended the uh uh uh application and so
really what you're just seeing is
they're getting prepared for the
approval the big question is are they
going to Jus do they know anything they
may know nothing either they may know
nothing but I don't think that uh Black
Rock is going to go through all this
effort right remember there's reputation
risk here in terms of people know what
they're doing and so it's much more
likely that it's going to get approved
you need a different change on who's in
charge I mean you've got three Democrats
and two Republicans right is that we we
had one of the Republicans on that and
she said I think it's I have no idea
it makes no sense it hasn't been
approved yet but that doesn't mean yet
that she's going to convince her her
colleagues at the end of the day Bitcoin
doesn't care about the politics of it
all right now the SEC and other
organizations definitely care well
here's the thing is Bitcoin is just
highly highly disciplined right it is
the most disciplined Central Bank in the
world it doesn't care what's going on in
the news it doesn't care about
geopolitics it just produces price of
Bitcoin does the price of Bitcoin cares
very much about what happened bitcoin's
up 100% to start this year right and I
don't think a lot of people kind of
recognize that because they remember it
was at 69,000 it drew down to 15 but
it's up 100% to start the year and so
when you look at that the market is
obviously telling us something and what
we're watching is capital is Flowing
someone's calling it a flight to Quality
you've seen not someone Larry Larry
right Larry versus bonds with let me let
me see if I have this right can the
government issue more than 21 million
bonds uh the government can issue as
much as they want right but how many
Bitcoin one of the most important 21
million one of the most important uh
details or or kind of data points that I
saw recently that really kind of opened
my eyes was TLT from the high in 2020
2021 is down about the same that Bitcoin
is and so we're bonds used to be this
flight to safety now all of a sudden
you're seeing people around the world
say look some people are still buying
bonds for sure but there are some other
people who are buying Bitcoin and given
that Bitcoin is the finite asset I think
that's ultimately where you get uh price
appreciation well Anthony the only thing
I was going to say is that the what
Washington does is very very important
if it weren't there wouldn't be so many
Bitcoin enthusiasts trying to do so much
to to spend money there and try and
influence if you look at Sam bankman
freed or anybody down the line what
Washington decides does matter and I
would think that having them decide
something would be helpful like just
getting rules of the road would probably
so I think that uh the companies that
deal with Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
they care what Washington is doing right
they're the ones who are spending the
money they're they're the ones who are
doing this Bitcoin is a decentralized
protocol Bitcoin is not spending any
money Bitcoin doesn't even have a team
behind it and so I think that the
companies very much care and they are
lobbying and they are trying to get
these Clarity of rules and try to you
know push this forward but Bitcoin
itself if the government tomorrow came
out and banned Bitcoin everyone else
around the world would say okay and they
probably would actually go buy it
because all of a sudden they would say
hey this is outside the system this is
something that isn't controlled by any
government it isn't controlled by any
individual and so it's this very
interesting thing where decentralization
of the protocol really matters but the
companies they're still centralized
companies with American citizens running
them and they definitely care what is
going on in Washington so you
think when above the old highs when and
how much higher above the old highs
hundreds of percent appreciation when we
get to these bull markets has been the
norm I don't see that changing now and
then back to where I mean look there's a
cycle right it's very much uh I mean
it's it's it's a hideous frightening
cycle that just shakes you to the core
when Bitcoin comes back down they went
to 17 from 65 right 69 people have been
on this show for years now talking about
all the stocks that went up a lot they
went down a lot over a long period of
time they were great Investments you
just kind of hold through all the
volatility I think Bitcoin is really
just the true free market asset right
there is no um you know circuit breakers
there is nobody bailing it out when uh
we saw FTX and other companies go under
the government didn't rush into bail
them out they bailed out the banks and
so I think that there is this element of
a free market asset is going to have way
more volatility than something that's
inside of the system you what's a little
weird this time Anthony is that you
wouldn't say that there's been risk on
in Tech over
that F the the right hand side of that
this has not been a risk on environment
from 25 to to 34 it's it's gone up 40%
in a riskof environment so that almost
looks like it's it's not correlated now
and that's where lar the think got the
flight that it's money which to call
Bitcoin quality is in a lot of people
mind that's anathema Charlie Munger
thinks it's rat chitzu one of the things
people have to remember is the best
investors in the world act completely
differently than the herd and so right
now the herd is saying we're risk off
every great investor I know is going
risk on they're buying these asset at
suppressed prices because they know
what's going to happen we're going to
return to loose monetary policy and
prices are going to go back up are we
though higher for longer higher for
longer higher for longer you you uh you
eventually run into math and ultimately
you have a$ 33. half trillion dollar
debt you added $500 billion dollar in
the last month we're sending hundreds of
billions of dollars around for these
proxy wars you just if you're going to
continue to raise the national debt
you're going to have to inflate it away
and so loose monetary policy is going to
be the standard over the coming let's go
back to this idea of and we've talked
about it on the broadcast a lot the sort
of buy the rumor sell the news situation
which is if in fact the CF exists or
there's a big announcement is that a
great day for Bitcoin or is that baked
into the price and you you needed to
have gotten there beforehand and
actually goes down afterwards I think
it's a great Point uh the having
historically have been this like by the
uh rumor seld the news events uh the ETF
probably is going to be something like
that where if you saw uh this fake news
I guess it was you know where the ETF
got approved but it really wasn't
approved basically price went up
thousands of dollars in a few minutes
then Drew right back down as soon as it
was uh determined that it was fake and
so you probably will get some sort of uh
short-term movement just out of the
excitement but I do think that this
anticipation is obviously driving the
price up it was 25,000 now it's 34,000
you're just eating into what was
potential Returns on the approval and so
uh the question isn't so much what
happens on day one right you know Galaxy
digital just came out with a research
report they think $14 billion will go
into the ETF in the first year if that
happens what does that do to the price
their expectation is that's going to
drive the price 75% higher and so that's
just their estimation around the ETF if
that's true that's a pretty big price
move for an asset that's already
hundreds of billions of dollars in
market cap um I like getting for the
people that are really in the cult I
mean there's even Nam so when is it I
mean a having almost soundss like like
an Awakening something when is the next
having when is it's coming isn't it yeah
less than a year
away I I do feel sometimes like we are
uh we're talking about things the same
way that uh people talk about you know
when is your birthday what is the you
know the having was coming the having is
coming Becky I've heard this yes Andrew
but I also understand where prepare I
know I know prepare for the having the
having is coming feel like on the
leftover what is the and I I love I'm
I'm I'm kiding around about it I think
it's great but um what's the stock to
flow right now what what is the number
do you know do you keep track of things
there's 900 Bitcoin that are coming into
circulation every single day it'll cut
down to 450 uh the reason why the having
is really important in my opinion is It
ultimately disproves the efficient
market hypothesis right if you think
about everyone knows that it's coming
but not everyone is going to act the
same some people think it's by the rumor
sell the news is with stock to flow is
it cheaper than Gold's stock to flow
right now I don't know what Gold's is um
but Bitcoin Bitcoin has continued to
become more and more attractive over
time and then again 76% of all Bitcoin
hasn't been sold in last year that's
from
$69,000 down to 15,000 back up to 34,000
when you start looking at these numbers
why are people not selling they
obviously have some sort of long-term
belief in an asset and so if you have a
highly liquid Market an ETF gets
approved tens of billions also some of
the craziest people on Twitter uh as you
know there's a report yesterday that the
Wall Street executive supposedly are
shocked at how much interest there are
in these products and I think that what
we're watching in some weird way is Wall
Street is being introduced to the
internet but now this time it's not the
internet vers Wall Street like we saw
with the meme stocks instead you're
seeing Wall Street and the internet
basically get on the same side of the
table and wall Street's getting excited
they're saying wait a second these
people are insane on the internet and
we're going to have an asset or a fund
that they want that could be really
interesting for us and so maybe actually
working together could be at a time when
there AR a lot of other fees on Wall
Street not IPOs not m&a activity so
they're looking for a place and it's
kind of cool you could be anywhere
really on the planet with in a place
where the currency is who knows what it
is in that country where you are and if
you have a phone you can have something
that's not going down with would you use
it I mean for what I for use it if I was
if I was unbanked I'd use it yeah I I
guess but you know we make fun of the
people who used it to pay for a pizza
I'm so is an invest it's got back to
34,000 going you're never going to want
to spend it but it's gotten back to
34,000 without anyone arguing it's used
as currency yeah I mean no one's arguing
that anymore I I do think it's a
rational to say the dollar is the
greatest of all time at the moment in
terms of medium of exchange right if you
want to spend something spend the dollar
Bitcoin has been the greatest of all
time in terms of a store of value right
and so people are buying it and they're
holding it obviously 76% of it sold in a
year and they're going to spend dollars
what the promise of Bitcoin is that it
will become electronic cash the like
dirty secret is if that never happens
I'm not saying that it is not going to
happen but if it never happens Bitcoin
is still going to be highly valuable
just as a store value and so there's
still a ton of upside and I think that's
why investors are excited all right pump
you uh I feel like we should have a
disclosure for you because you're so I
own Bitcoin so do I but you're so you're
so rabid that I mean people need to know
how rabid you are in terms of Bitcoin
and just take that into account that you
could be totally F right may maybe but
uh you know I say people lie markets
don't and all the things you say if you
look into it closely it it is it doesn't
care what anyone says about it yeah
Bitcoin pretty unique yeah thanks
Anthony